- 양자 정보와 계산의 이해에
다시 오신 것을 환영해요.
저는 John Watrous이고
IBM Quantum Education의 기술 디렉터예요.
이번은 시리즈의 세 번째 수업이에요. 처음 두 수업에서는 양자 정보의
기초에 대해 이야기했어요.
먼저 단일 시스템을 독립적으로 살펴보고, 그다음에 다중 시스템을 다뤘어요.
또한 표준 기저 측정과
유니터리 연산에 대해서도 단일 시스템과
다중 시스템 환경 모두에서 논의했어요.
이번 수업에서는 quantum circuit 모델을
소개할 거예요. 이것은 양자 계산을 설명하는 표준적인 방법을 제공해요.
그리고 quantum circuit을 사용해서 양자 프로토콜과 여러 양자 장치를 포함하는 다양한 종류의 상호작용을 설명할 수도 있어요.
quantum circuit 외에도, 양자 정보와
관련된 몇 가지 중요한 수학적 개념도 논의할 거예요.
그리고 이를 사용해서 양자 정보의
몇 가지 근본적인 한계와 quantum circuit으로 할 수 있는 것들을 살펴볼 거예요.
이것은 다음 수업을 위한 좋은 준비가 될 거예요.
다음 수업에서는 매우 중요한 몇 가지 예제를 보고
시리즈의 첫 번째 단원을 마무리할 거예요.
양자 정보의 기초에 대한 내용이에요.
수업의 개요는 이래요. quantum circuit 모델부터 시작해서 어떻게 작동하는지 알아볼 거예요.
그다음에 매우 중요한 개념인
내적에 대해 이야기하고, 직교정규성과 사영에 대해서도 다룰 거예요.
이것들은 내적과 관련이 있어요. 처음 두 수업에서는
이런 것들을 논의하지 않았는데, 정말로 필요하지 않았기 때문이에요. 하지만 이제는 필요해요.
내적은 없으면 안 되는
수학적 도구를 제공해요.
내적 없이는 양자 정보와
계산을 이해하는 데 멀리 나아갈 수 없어요.
수업의 세 번째 부분에서는 양자 정보의
몇 가지 중요한 한계를 살펴볼 거예요.
궁극적으로 우리가 하고 싶은 것은 양자 정보로
할 수 있는 흥미로운 것들을 탐구하는 것인데, 이를 효과적으로 하려면
할 수 없는 것들에 대해서도
알아야 해요.
특히 글로벌 위상의 개념과
글로벌 위상이 왜 관련이 없는지에 대해 논의할 거예요.
복제 불가능 정리의 설명도 볼 거예요.
이것은 양자 상태를 일반적으로 복사할 수 없다는 것을 알려주고, 두 양자 상태가
직교하지 않으면 완벽하게
구별할 수 없다는 것도 볼 거예요. 이것은 알아두어야 할 근본적인 한계예요.
수업의 첫 번째 주제는
quantum circuit 모델이에요. 이것은 양자 계산을
설명하는 방법을 제공하는 계산 모델이에요.
양자 계산을 설명하는 거예요.
quantum circuit 모델은 컴퓨터 과학에서
circuit이라는 더 일반적인 개념에 기반하고 있고, 이 일반적인 개념을 바탕으로 많은
다양한 계산 모델을 정의할 수 있어요.
이 일반적인 개념에 기반해서요.
기본 아이디어는 circuit이 정보를 전달하는
와이어와 연산을 나타내는 gate로 구성된다는 거예요.
와이어가 전달하는 정보에
연산이 적용되는 거예요.
circuit이라는 용어는 사실
이런 종류의 모델에 사용하기에는 좀 이상한 이름이에요. 왜냐하면 circuit이라는 단어는
보통 어떤 종류의
순환 경로를 의미하거든요.
하지만 계산 모델로서의 circuit을
이야기할 때는 보통 비순환 circuit을 말하는 거예요.
순환 경로가 허용되지 않는 거죠.
더 정확히 말하면, 이 시리즈에서는
정보가 항상 어떤 circuit에서든 왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 흐르도록 요구할 거예요.
원한다면, circuit을 시간이
왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 흐르는 연산의 시퀀스를 설명하는 것으로 생각할 수 있어요.
여기 불리언 circuit의 예가 있어요. 와이어가 이진
값, 즉 0 또는 1을 전달하고,
gate는 불리언
논리 연산을 나타내요.
와이어는 선으로 표현되고, 여기 X와 Y라는
레이블이 붙은 두 개의 입력 비트가 있어요.
특정 입력 선택에 대해 circuit이
무엇을 하는지 알고 싶으면, 와이어의 값을
왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 전파하면 돼요.
gate가 와이어에 의해 전달되는
값에 대해 수행하는 동작에 따라서요.
예를 들어, 위쪽 입력 와이어를
값 1로, 아래쪽 입력 와이어를 값 0으로
설정했을 때 어떤 일이 일어나는지 살펴볼 수 있어요.
이 두 입력 와이어는 여기 있는
이 두 점으로 연결되는데, 이것은 팬아웃 연산을 나타내요. 즉, 값이 복사되어서
여러 와이어를 따라
앞으로 전달될 수 있는 거예요.
이렇게 하면 이 두 와이어는
값 1을 가지게 되는데, 이것과 같고, 이 두 와이어는 값 0을 가지게 되는데,
이것과 같아요.
여기 NOT gate가 있는데, 논리 부정
기호로 표시되어 있어요. 그래서 나오는 값은 0이에요.
이것은 1의 논리 부정이에요. 마찬가지로
이 gate에서 나오는 값은 1인데, 이것은
0의 논리 부정이에요.
이 두 gate는 AND gate이고,
이 gate는 OR gate예요. 계속해서
값을 전파하면